all right guys
bang bang pierre is back
thank you so much for doing this on
short notice there my friend
yeah sure thing thanks for having me on
pomp of course um
all right you've had an eventful weekend
but before we get to uh to that
let's start with um anyone who didn't
listen uh
previously just give us kind of a quick
you know 60 seconds on
uh you your background and kind of what
you've done in bitcoin
yeah sure so i graduated from ut austin
hookum in 2013 with a
bachelor and master in accounting
and they've got the number one
accounting program in the nation there
i'd argue maybe in the world
um and i enjoyed that a lot because i
was interested in learning about
accounting
from an austrian economics perspective
i'd studied austrian economics when i
was in high school
i was really into gold and sound money
back in 2005 before
anyone was before bitcoin was even a
glimmer in satoshi's eye right
and i wanted to get into accounting
because
ludwig von mises had this quote about
how that's how
uh business people can make decisions
right the profit and loss system
the price system that's aggregating all
this information in a very complex
economy
um and you know that that that that i
found really appealing more appealing
really than than
finance itself um i kind of wanted to
see how the numbers
uh you know got put together uh and
i graduated in 2013 immediately started
learning how to program
because i didn't like the uh bookkeeping
part of accounting i didn't like
having to copy paste things manually and
all this so
i wanted to automate that part so i
could focus on
uh you know the the interesting parts of
accounting and
i got interested in software development
itself so
that's what caused me to to learn python
and sql and to
pursue that as a career rather than
accounting
um so i worked in big four at deloitte i
worked
at hudson river trading which is a high
frequency trading shop in in new york in
their back office
um and i worked at bitpay too which is a
bitcoin payment processor
in atlanta so um since then
uh you know i've all along i've been
very interested in bitcoin i got
interested in bitcoin back in 2013
and uh something that i i found really
fascinating about it was
because of my accounting background i
realized the value
of being able to reconcile all of these
numbers in real time
and to have a transparent immutable
ledger
so it immediately clicked with me
combined with like the scarcity
uh supply schedule of it where uh with
my sound money like austrian economics
background
uh that part also clicked with me that
hey
this is this is inherently going to
appeal
to to different people um an increase in
value over the long term because
this the unit itself on the ledger is
scarce it's not like wow gold you know
where
a company can just issue as much as they
want um so yeah that's the
that's the tl dr on on me all right
uh you are one of the strongest
most public proponents of bitcoin uh you
do a fantastic job
um talking about all the the positive
aspects all the
uh other things i have not heard you
talk that much about ethereum
or ether uh and this weekend all of a
sudden
chaos breaks out what exactly happened
like take us back to what was kind of
the the impetus for all of this
yeah sure so i mean we could go all the
way back to the ethereum pre-sale
because
i was i was around back then and um
i i personally was skeptical that it was
going to launch
and they proved me wrong right um they
did the pre-sale they actually launched
the product which i gotta hand it to
them because that's
fairly rare in crypto right that someone
gets all the money up front and then
actually executes
and um actually is able to build a
self-sustaining ecosystem so i think
that
they deserve a lot of credit for that
and i was skeptical from the from the
get-go that they would
succeed at doing that and
uh yeah so i didn't really have um big
reasons to criticize ethereum
my view at this point is really that um
bitcoin can succeed and altcoins can
succeed as well
um and so that's because that's what
we've seen over the past 10 years
so that's just like an empirical
observation of what has been happening
and
i just expect that to continue to happen
that um
these like these all these different
systems
you know in different iterations and yes
of course some will fail and fall by the
wayside or you know
become unpopular or whatever but that um
largely like the reason bitcoin is going
to succeed is not
because it is better than altcoins it's
because
it's better than the status quo uh and
uh it's better than the us dollar like i
really do see it as competition between
bitcoin and the us dollar
um and then the competition about like
us dollar versus euro
or litecoin versus dogecoin like those
are
secondary considerations because we're
not
really talking about the the the title
fight right of the night uh the the two
heavyweights here so
um any in any case uh so i i don't talk
about ethereum very much
uh but i you know this this came up
over the past week because there was a
lot of back and forth between
um bitcoin proponents and ethereum
proponents
about uh the relative merits of these
systems
and um there's a view that like they're
not even
comparable right that uh it's actually
unfair to judge one
using the criteria of the other and
there's kind of a fundamental values
debate
um between uh these these two systems
um i think that's that's plausible
um i actually though when i look at what
decentralization means to me it's all
about verification
and it's not just that i'm saying that
because
like my background is an auditor and so
you know that's just like where my mind
goes
um i think that a lot of the software
engineers who work in this area
uh would agree that verification is
really one of the key parts
of keeping these decentralized systems
decentralized
and immutable if nobody's verifying
anything then
anything can happen right and we've seen
that with the federal reserve
that's why people are always saying hey
let's audit the fed
um and uh you know they they want to dig
into the the details of what's going on
so that we can figure out is there's
something bad happening or
are we not achieving good outcomes that
we want um
is there embezzlement or fraud going on
all these i think are valid questions
and
you know merit verification so in any
case the nice thing about
cryptocurrencies is that we can use
cryptography right it's right there in
the name crypto
cryptography to do the verification
right where
um you know someone does a cryptographic
signature
and then others can verify that that
signature is in fact
valid and that's kind of what causes
bitcoins to be transferred from one
person to another is
uh the villa validity of cryptographic
signatures
um so that's kind of on the transfer
part and then on the issuance part we're
also able to to verify the issuance
because
um and i'll i'll mention i'll keep this
conversation focused on bitcoin right
because we're going to get to ethereum
but
in bitcoin um you know every every time
bitcoin are issued
um it's because a miner is proposing a
block to the
network to add to the blockchain and
when they do that um you know the the
the process by which they do that is
called hashing
and what they're doing when they're
hashing is that they're trying to get a
certain number of leading zeros
in some random output the input is not
random
the input is actually the block header
data
and it contains a lot of information but
the salient part
is the uh difficulty which is going to
determine how many leading zeros you
need to have in your hash
and which is going to determine how much
hashing you're going to have to do
in order to be able to submit a block
for
um to the network um
and other the the guiding principle in
this proof-of-work system is that
it is very expensive to propose a block
and then
on the other side it's very inexpensive
it's very affordable to verify
a block right so then we can double
check this work without having to redo
all the work
because we can just uh do the the
cryptography
uh very quick uh verification
on the on the node side and so this
creates a balance of power
in the system where it's not like the
miners
control how many bitcoin get created
it's actually this decentralized
peer-to-peer network of nodes
that is receiving proposed blocks and
double checking them to make sure that
the miner is following all the rules
and that they have in fact found a a
valid proof of work
so basically the way that this system
works is
uh one like you just described the
miners are proposing blocks
they then get uh added to the blockchain
through a process
uh if you run a node at any point you
can query the blockchain and you can get
a whole bunch of information
right and that information can skew from
super complex nuanced things around the
blockchain
to just how many bitcoin exist right um
and uh the chaos this past weekend came
down to
uh if you ran a query with a bitcoin
node
uh on the bitcoin blockchain at the same
time anywhere in the world
you and multiple people did it they all
got the same answer here's how many
bitcoin are in the circulating supply
if you did that same exact thing on the
ethereum network
people started getting different answers
and so
at high level i think people say why
maybe before we get to the why just
describe how did you uncover the fact
that people were getting different
answers like where where what like where
did you first see oh wait there might be
an issue or people might not actually
have the answer to this question
yeah um it's funny i i know that at some
point
over the past five years somewhere i
read a tweet that you could not
calculate
the total amount of eth out there
with just a command line thing and
um so that was planted in my mind at
some point over the past five years i
don't i can't point to it
specifically um but then when i started
uh seeing some of the debates uh over uh
the past
week about running an ethereum node and
uh this verification
that resurfaced to my mind and i was
like wait did did they
did they write this piece of software so
let's talk about three different numbers
there's the total issuance which is kind
of a
like how what's the total amount of
bitcoin or of ethereum
or eth that could have been created
while following the protocol rules so
that's kind of the
theoretical issuance right and you could
you could derive that
just by looking at what their issuance
formulas are
um the second number is the total supply
so um let's say
okay so there can be a total number of
21 million bitcoin issued
subtract from that all of the bitcoin
that have not been issued
so far right um so that's about three
million bitcoin
um and then subtract from that
historically
there have been bugs in some minor
software
which caused them to not claim bitcoin
that they were entitled to claim
and so we're actually below issuance
because of that um and
you can you can do this math you can
reconcile these numbers and you know
exactly
you can point to which blocks are
lacking the
the what's called the block reward right
the total amount of bitcoin those owed
so so there's there's um and then
there's the third number of
circulating supply um that that's really
a number that nobody could really know
because
the concept there is that someone might
have
lost their private keys and so they no
longer have access to the underlying
asset
and so well you know hypothetically we
should just remove that from the supply
but how are we going to know that
someone actually lost the keys
versus it's just been a long time since
they have transferred the asset
and we kind of want to have the
presumption that
someone can transfer bitcoin to their
keys
and sit on those keys for years and
not um you know have any concerns about
needing to refresh that or needing to
you know rotate their keys or anything
like that assuming that their their
private key management is secure um so
circulating supply is really unknowable
uh we there are estimates um
of how many bitcoin have been lost using
various heuristics
but ultimately that's not the part that
interests me because that's not
something i can audit
the first two numbers are numbers that i
can audit i can i can
i can derive the issuance number and
then
i can go and add up on bitcoin what you
do is you
add up what are called unspent
transaction outputs
and so that's kind of the current ledger
balance
right of okay how many uh
bitcoin are locked up to how many
addresses
um so that's the utxo set and you can
just sum that up it takes a
few seconds and you've got the total uh
supply
uh ethereum is much more complex than
that so
uh you have uh you don't they don't have
the
output model what they have is called an
account
model and so you have to go into all of
these accounts
and add them all up now
this is this is orders of magnitude more
data than the utxo set
and i would argue that that makes
ethereum less scalable
but it's actually it's not fair to them
because that's not what they're
optimizing for
they're optimizing for something
completely different which is trying to
have
expressive smart contracts and so it
this is where you know we can get into
like okay
why would we judge ethereum's account
based model
against bitcoin's output based model
because those are two different
uh trade-offs right and that's fair i
just want to highlight that
what you're trading off is your ability
to
get a solid accounting for the total
supply
uh yeah and it feels like in this
scenario right you've got
uh bitcoin which has a very
uh understood simple framework
that is all about uh provability uh when
it comes to supply
um and ultimately scarcity right so i
can
prove to you that there's 21 million
total bitcoin that will ever get created
i can prove to you the 18 and you know
million and change bitcoin
have actually uh been issued and then i
can
um i cannot prove to you what the
current
circulating supply is because of the
issues you described
when you then go and you apply those
things to
ethereum i think a lot of people are
asking the question well is this
bad if all of a sudden
if you have a public transparent ledger
with a digital asset that's supposed to
operate on a decentralized
permissionless network
but you can't prove some of those things
is that
not maybe not fatal but is that a red
flag or is that an
issue and i think that's really kind of
what you raised the flag on and was
saying wait a second
i can't do this why can't i do it or who
has the answer correct
yeah and um i i think that we're getting
close to an answer
the latest reconciliation i've seen uh
was
able to if i'm reading it correctly
because frankly they didn't really
format it to where i i don't know if
they're plugging a number or if they
actually
separately calculated this number of
ethereum that have been destroyed of
ether that have been destroyed so
um i think that we're within about 2 400
each
of um kind of having the reconciliation
done
um i you know i i kind of found it
this whole thing has been surprising to
me from the beginning because
i thought that this would be pretty
buttoned up that like the
that this wouldn't be an issue because
um you know
it's not impossible what i'm asking for
and it's been interesting to see uh if
prominent ethereum influencers imply
that i'm asking for something
unreasonable
or something that can't cannot be
calculated
and i think they're wrong it can be
calculated they've just never done it
before
and i think that you know it does speak
to to the ethereum
culture and kind of the the value
proposition that they have
um i what i find disappointing
is that they have been promoting this
narrative
that eth can compete with bitcoin as a
store of value
and i just fundamentally disagree with
that because
of what you you were mentioning um
and also because of the actions of the
ethereum
community right like if if if if their
response to me had been
hey you're right we're fixing this right
now
and it was over in a matter of hours
that would be great
but we're on like day four or five right
now and
we're down to 2400 east but you know
we're not down to zero which is kind of
what i look for in an audit is to have
it foot to zero
well and and i think part of this um
because i'm with you right like
you know to clear the state and i wrote
about it this morning uh we're recording
this on monday
uh and we're gonna release in the next
day or two but uh when i
originally uh wrote the piece i said
look i'm a fan of ethereum the network
like i actually believe that it can
empower a whole bunch of things that
bitcoin doesn't empower like it is
solving a different problem and my whole
point is like
ethereum should go double down on what
it's great at and bitcoin should go
double down on what it's on what it is
great at and forget all the maximalism
and tribalism and like all that nonsense
and so i appreciate i think that you've
got a similar view in that
the one thing that i'll say though is uh
i was
shocked as it sounds like you were at
the
cavalierness and the nonchalantness of
the ethereum community when you ask the
question like to simply ask like hey can
you calculate this
uh to be told we're close enough and it
comes out that you know it's like 300
000 uh ether apart or about 130 140
million bucks
it's kind of like wait a second like
well i saw somebody tweet i said
if they think that you're close enough
on this well what else are they close
enough on
right and and it starts to kind of like
you start to poke a little bit you're
like wait a second there's some smoke
here like
is is there a fire and and not in the
sense of like ethereum's gonna fail
but you just start to get this sense of
like wait there might not be as much
first principles thinking as i
previously thought
right there might not be a sense of
urgency like i previously thought
and so it doesn't necessarily gonna
change you know if you're a hardcore
ethereum or ether believer i don't think
you're gonna change your mind over this
but it was surprising and unexpected in
my opinion the reaction that you got
specifically
yeah and and to be clear like i don't
think anyone listening to this
should go out and make a financial
decision based on what i'm saying
all i'm asking them to do is to do some
some research and to really scratch
under the surface on these assets
and to figure out um what i consider to
be kind of like due diligence questions
right of
how many how many exist how how did they
come about existing
how many are going to exist in the
future and you know that's kind of
like corporate governance right you want
to know what the cap table looks like
and you want to know who's authorized to
issue more shares
what is the process around that like
because if you don't do that then you
run the risk of getting diluted out
and you have to be able to protect your
rights right defend your rights as an
investor
and the way you do it with these
decentralized systems is by running a
node
and by running the numbers right adding
it all up
of seeing what percentage of this ledger
do i own
uh you know and and that way you're able
to to make some
and that's where i think it's really
important is to have like the highest
quality information out there
and it was surprising to see like
vitalik
point to coin market cap as uh
his trusted you know data provider for
how many eth exist um i i think that you
know that should be open source
it should not be a proprietary number
that is only calculated by a select
few of people who work at coinmarketcamp
or who work at another data provider
i think that anyone in the ethereum
community should have
access to the tools for uh
doing the math and figuring out what's
the total supply out there
and i think part of this too is it's not
a anti-any third-party
data provider specifically right it's
just simply saying
the third-party data provider should be
able to calculate for their
needs but so should you and you should
be able to verify
what is it the party data site you
should be able to verify what's on the
blockchain all that kind of stuff
um so so i think that that's like pretty
non-controversial i
i i think would be fooling ourselves if
we said
if this same issue was brought up by
somebody who was not a bitcoin proponent
it probably would be handled differently
right like like to me it feels like
um there was just this reaction of like
we're being attacked almost
uh and so my hope is that eventually
that stuff kind of dissipates and people
realize
um yeah there's kind of a better way to
work together to some degree
um and so maybe talk a little bit about
uh you issued a bitcoin bounty
which you know as i wrote uh i find
hilarious
that a bitcoin proponent is literally
paying for the creation of something
that helps the ethereum community
uh but if you kind of take away the the
irony with that
um what kind was your thought process uh
behind the
the bitcoin bounty and then where does
that stand now yeah sure i mean so
fundamentally like ethereum is the
number two asset in this space
and um if something bad were to happen
to ethereum i actually think that would
reflect poorly on bitcoin as well
um so i think that if if
as a whole we're as a whole industry
right we're going to say
these are decentralized immutable
ledgers that we're building
then we should work towards that and i
kind of want everyone to have the same
expectations on that um so
i i do think that the end result is
going to be that we have a clean audit
right and that
um there aren't going to be any uh
surprise
surprises at the end of the day that's
my expectation we'll see if we get there
but um
the if if we get that then i think that
it increases confidence
in this space overall and including in
bitcoin i think that there really is
a positive effect here um especially
from
like an education perspective of why
did pierre go through this exercise like
why did it matter and i've seen a lot of
people asking about that like
why does this matter that that we're
doing this
and it's about decentralization uh if
we're going to trust
centralized third parties then we might
as well just go back to the federal
reserve right like we
and i know that there's there's also a
spectrum right so like
some things are going to be more
decentralized than others so for example
you might
argue well um you know aren't you
trusting the developers who are writing
the script that's all true
and that's why when i did the bounty the
bounty is still up
i don't want just one script right now i
have i have two scripts i have a script
that calculates the issuance rate and i
have a script that calculates the
the total supply so currently
outstanding
but um i i don't have a reconciliation
between those two scripts
and i also don't have uh separate
iterations of those scripts so
in auditing you always want to be um
recalculating what the client has given
you and so
you don't just want to have like one
methodology you want to have multiple
so that you know maybe even write them
in different programming languages and
with different approaches and with
different sets of
sanity tests so that you can have a lot
of confidence
in the end result and i
i think that um so i'm going to keep the
bounty up
the the bounty is a million satoshis
which if you do the math that's about a
hundred dollars
although you know the exchange rates
feel like very volatile it's going up
generally so it's it's more than a
hundred dollars now
um but uh you're gonna have to pay
income tax on it because it is you know
compensation for
for work done um and the so the the
grant i created because
i really think that it's hard to get
developers to
open source their code and to do work
for free
um and and it also i felt like
mitigated the critique of you are doing
this in bad things
right that you're just trolling well you
know if i put money up
and you know okay i could put up more
than a million satoshis if
if that's what i need to do i'll put up
more than a million satoshi's but right
now
you know i think that a million's a fair
price for what i'm asking for
everyone says it's a simple script so i
feel like 100 bucks should be okay for a
simple script
but it's turning out to be fairly
complicated so maybe i'll have to
increase the bounty
i also wanted to use this opportunity to
talk about satoshi's because
uh saying a million satoshis and i'm
going to make someone a millionaire is
provocative
but i think that one of the problems in
this space has been
the issue of um kind of
the the numbers bias of oh one bitcoin
is too expensive i can't afford
ten thousand dollars so i can't buy
bitcoin and
uh that's actually wrong because
bitcoins divisible out to 100 million
satoshi's
and so when i say a million satoshis
that's a hundred dollars
so if you know a 100 000 satoshi's is 10
so anyone can buy a bitcoin is my my
point there
yeah look and and i think that part of
this too is
um although there will be many people
who disagree uh the idea
of uh one identifying a problem and two
i do think it's a good faith effort of
uh hey i'll pay somebody to create this
solution here
um frankly it was pretty clever on your
part so it's uh
it's pretty interesting to see uh before
we finish up what do you think
um is kind of the outcome here right or
like what do you hope that
uh we end up you know over the next
couple of days or weeks
yeah so there's a couple of different
considerations one is that
um if if we get the reconciliation
working
you still need to run a full ethereum
node to actually
do it to actually run those scripts so
i'm going to start syncing an ethereum
node and
that way i'll be able to double check
the work that i'm paying for
secondly is thinking about kind of the
roadmap going forward
the ethereum community is hard at work
on ethereum 2.0
and unfortunately ethereum 2.0
makes what i'm talking about even more
complex
of adding up the total supply um because
of sharding
now not only do you have different
accounts but they're going to be on
different shards
and so the if ethereum 2.0 is
extremely successful and a lot of people
use it
it's going to become extremely expensive
to count up the whole supply of eth
on ethereum 2.0 and
if it becomes too expensive and nobody
can do it
i think that introduces a vulnerability
whereby um your eth could get diluted
and uh you're really um in the dark
as to whether when you're buying eth are
you actually
receiving legit eath or is this
fractional reserve ether that was kind
of created out thin
air but nobody's running a full node so
there's no way to to know so
i think the this really impacts the
scaling debate
and uh the debate about the direction
ethereum 2.0 is going in
now maybe you know maybe that's okay
right that we can have a world computer
where
the math is a little fuzzy on what the
underlying asset is
and the metaphor that they use which i
think is plausible
is that ethan's like oil you don't need
to know the current supply of oil at all
times
you just want to put it in your tank and
use it right
so maybe that's the case with heath is
that you just want to put it
in your wallet and you know get utility
out of it in various ways you don't
actually need to know the total supply
because you're not going to be a
long-term investor in east
i think that's a a great perspective of
like
these two things do two different things
and they should both double down on what
they do well
right kind of this idea of ethan's money
doesn't make a lot of sense to me i
think there's a lot of people in even
the ethereum community that says that
doesn't make sense to them either
but but i think that we're headed to a
world where uh i love how you opened it
up with just like
more than one thing can win it what
they're trying to accomplish because
they're trying to accomplish different
things right
yeah that's right and i think that if we
want to bring it back to
a debate it's like all right which of
these has the biggest total addressable
market
which of these is going to accrue value
but those are kind of like different
um and it gets religious right uh people
have lots of opinions
the market's gonna decide um what's
needed for the market to decide though
is is clear and accurate information
and so that's something i want to
continue to promote i love it
um listen thank you so much for uh for
jumping on uh so quickly but
uh where can people find you um or find
more of the work that you're doing
yeah sure thing so um go on twitter
at pierre underscore richard it's a fire
hose of information
especially on a weekend like this where
everyone's
working really hard crunching numbers um
but that's that's where to find me and
my dms are open so if you want to chat
and
and talk about different questions you
might have um i'm available that way
you uh you you were cranking out the
tweets this weekend i was loving every
second of it
and and frankly i thought uh you
navigated nicely between the uh
uh the smart ass comments and also the
uh the actual
kind of uh substantive ones of uh let's
try to figure out a solution to this so
uh
hopefully people realize that uh this
will be a plus one i think in
the history of ethereum and also in
bitcoin at some point
thanks pomp have a good one